das ist neu der größte trojaner der erde
wurde jetzt entdeckt ein asteroid mit
einem durchmesser von sagenhaften 1,2
kilometern doch woher kommt er wie lange
wird er unseren planeten begleiten
könnte er uns gefährlich werden oder
können wir das neu aufgespürte objekt
möglicherweise sogar bald besuchen auf
jeden fall ergeben sich durch den fund
höchst spannende perspektiven für die
raumfahrt zum science and future bis
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und
aktivierte glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
von wegen ganz alleine unterwegs die
erde hat auf ihrer bahn um die sonne so
einige begleiter und zwar nicht nur den
mond astronomen und astronomen konnten
bereits einige mini monde aus spüren die
aufgrund der schwerkraft eingefangen
wurden zudem gibt es asteroiden die die
spur unserer erde immer mal wieder
kreuzen der großteil dieser erdnahen
asteroiden stammt ursprünglich aus dem
asteroidengürtel zwischen jupiter mars
durch kollisionen oder andere
störfaktoren wurden sie umgelenkt und
bewegen sich jetzt
hufeisenförmig um unsere erde es handelt
sich um exzentrische elliptischen orbit
durch das innere sonnensystem so auch
der erst 2010 s u 16 1 bis zu 400 meter
großer gesteinsbrocken mit einem
sogenannten hufeisen orbit dadurch dass
die schwerkraft in solch einer
umlaufbahn quasi abstoßend wirkt ist das
risiko einer kollision ausgeschlossen
astronomie teams weltweit verstehen
unter trojanern also nicht schädliche
computerprogramme oder die bewohnerinnen
und bewohner des antiken troja 7 eine
ganz besondere himmelskörper asteroiden
die einen planeten auf seiner umlaufbahn
begleiten ihm also entweder hinterher
ein oder opfer voraus sind solche
trojaner sind vor allem von anderen
planeten unseres sonnensystems bekannt
doch jetzt die spektakuläre entdeckung
ein gut ein kilometer große asteroid
begleitet die erde auf ihrer bahn um die
sonne was wissen wir also bislang über
unseren kosmischen begleiter die
spannende infos zu diesem thema bekommt
er jetzt hier
der riesenplanet jupiter ist ganz vorne
mit dabei er kommt auf knapp 10.000
solcher trojaner in seinem fall jupiter
trojaner teilweise sind diese brocken
bis zu 250 kilometer groß sie sammeln
sich an zwei stellen vor oder hinter dem
planeten in der fachsprache ist von la
danse punkten geregelt hier halten sich
die anziehungskräfte von sonnen jupiter
die waage und so sind die objekte in der
lage in stabilen umlaufbahn um diese
punkte zu kreis beim jupiter sind es
zwei große wolken solche asteroiden die
sich um seine lagrange punkte 4 und 5
konzentriert diese wiederum liegen
jeweils 60 grad vor und hinter dem
planeten und folgen ihm auf seinem orbit
um die sonne im herbst des vergangenen
jahres 2021 hat in die nasa die
raumsonde lucy zu einer ganz
spektakulären mission starten lassen
diese sonde hatte sich auf den weg
gemacht um zuerst mal überhaupt die
jupiter trojaner zu besuchen und genauer
ins visier zu nehmen ganz besonders
spannende erkenntnisse erhoffen sich
fachleute weltweit von diesen besonderen
besuch denn diese jupiter trojaner
stammen aus den äußeren bereich des
sonnensystems wie haben sich diese
fernen regionen entwickelt und über
welche routen gelangen asteroiden und
kometen ins innere system diese und noch
viele weitere fragen sollen mit der
hilfe von lucy geklärt werden doch bis
dahin müssen wir noch etwas geduld haben
denn um die beiden trojaner wolken an
den la das zu erreichen muss die sonne
einige schleifen fliegen und schwung
holen erst 2027 sollen sie dann den
schwarm von jupiter trojanern erreichen
die den planeten am lagrell 4 voraus ein
bis november 2028 wird lucy hier eine
lange besuchsliste abarbeiten bis sie
dann wieder zurück ins innere
sonnensystem bis zur erde gelenkt wird
eine spektakuläre premiere in der
geschichte der raumfahrt von der erde
kanten astronomen astronomen weltweit
bislang nur einen derartigen begleiter
denn die fahndung nach solchen
erdbegleiter gestaltet sich äußerst
kompliziert denn die lacrosse punkte 4
und 5 kommen nur in der dämmerung ins
blickfeld der ert basierten teleskope
punkt zudem steigen sie nicht sehr hoch
über den horizont auf ihre beobachtung
ist somit extrem schwierig der erste und
bislang einzige bekannte er trojaner mit
der bezeichnung t k 7 ist es vor rund
elf jahren 2011 entdeckt worden er ist
etwa 300 meter groß und bewegt sich um
dem lagrange punkt 4 hier bilden
himmelskörper mit der erde und der sonne
ein gleichzeitiges dreieck und genau das
stabilisiert die barden dieser objekte
und tk 7 hat jetzt gesellschaft bekommt
ein spanisches forschungsteam hat in
einer aktuellen studie die entdeckung
eines zwei trojaner bekannt gegeben sein
name
2020 accent fünf dieser asteroid könnte
nach ansicht der fachleute an
durchmesser von 1,2 kilometern haben und
damit rund dreimal größer sein als 2010
tk 7 damit handelt es sich bei dem neu
entdeckten trojaner um den größten
bekannten trojaner der erde aufgespürt
werden konnte der 23 jahren bereits im
dezember 2000 20.2 mit der hilfe der
panthers 1 himmelsdurchmusterung dazu
einer der beteiligten astronomen toni
santana ross das orbitale verhalten von
us 2020 xl fünf deutete darauf hin dass
es sich um einen weiteren kandidaten für
einen trojaner handeln könnte doch trotz
intensiver bemühungen waren die
forschenden nicht in der lage die bahnen
dieses brockens präzise genug zu
bestimmen somit musste das chilenische
so hat der disco unterstützung leisten
doch auch hier gab es probleme dazu
berichtet das forschungsteam das war
ziemlich schwierig war das objekt in der
morgendämmerung sehr tief am westlichen
horizont strom somit konnte die flugbahn
des erst zu jedem so weit eingegrenzt
werden dass das objekt auch in den
archivaufnahmen des dark energy server
das aus den jahren 2012 bis 2019
identifiziert werden konnte letztendlich
gelang es also doch seine umlaufbahn zu
bestimmen und somit eben auch der
nachweis dass es sich um ein eher
trojaner handelt der der erde am la
danse punkt 11 4 voraus läuft doch zudem
gestaltete es sich schwierig einen
genauen steckbrief des asteroiden
anzufertigen denn die
beobachtungsbedingungen waren nur mäßig
und das neu entdeckte himmelsobjekt
konnte lediglich kurz vor der dämmerung
ins visier genommen werden dennoch gehen
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler in der aktuellen studie
davon aus dass es sich bei 2020 25 um
einen asteroiden vom typ c handeln
könnte ein asteroid der über ein und
kohlenstoff anteil verfügt und somit
recht dunkel ist das legen zumindest
erste foto metrische analysen nach die
fachleute sind sich sicher dass der
trojaner nicht vor ort entstanden ist
sondern es sich wohl um einen asteroiden
handel der ursprünglich dem
asteroidengürtel entstammt das soeben
das typ c haben ihren ursprung im
äußeren teil des asteroidengürtels
zwischen mars und jupiter doch wie wurde
er dann zum begleiter der erde dazu die
aktuelle studie eine mögliche erklärung
seiner flugbahn könnte daher sein dass
er durch eine bahn resonanzen mit dem
jupiter aus dem haupt gürtel
geschleudert um dann vom la danse punkt
eingefangen wurde und möglicherweise
geistert noch gar nicht so lange um den
labors punkt vier die fachleute konnten
herausfinden dass seine waren stark
geneigt und exzentrisch ist
möglicherweise wurde also erst vor rund
500 jahren an seinem jetzigen
aufenthaltsort gefangen und fest steht
auch dass er die erde nicht für immer
begleiten wird modellsimulationen
offenbaren dass du hast du ihn bereits
in 4000 jahren sein orbit um den
lagrange punkt 4 verlassen könnte doch
möglicherweise verstecken sich da
draußen noch mehr er trojaner da sind
sich die fachleute sicher dazu heißt es
in der studie künftige suchen der region
um 11 4 und 11 5 könnten es uns erlauben
die populationen der trojaner weiter
einzugrenzen und vielleicht auch noch
natürlichere vertreter zu finden
möglicherweise sind wir sogar zukünftig
in der lage unsere trojaner zu besuchen
günstig wäre das wohl nicht doch
ausgeschlossen ist es keinesfalls die la
danse punkte mit irdischen sondern zu
erreichen und das könnte ungeahnte
möglichkeiten bieten genau darauf hoffen
die astronomen gastronomen wenn wir mehr
er trojaner entdecken während sie
billiger zu erreichen als der mond sie
könnten daher ideale base für die
weitere erkundung des sonnensystems
prüfen oder sogar eine quelle von
rohstoffen klar ist jedenfalls
asteroiden kometen und meteoriten
verfügen oft über sehr hohe
konzentrationen von edelmetallen oder
seltenen erden metallen es gibt
berechnungen nach denen ein etwa ein
kilometer großes objekt den heutigen
bedarf an industriemetallen denken
könnte das für jahrzehnte die nasa geht
davon aus dass allein im
asteroidengürtel zwischen jupiter und
mars gold nickel und eisen im wert von
etwa
700 quint millionen dollar zu finden
sind 700 millionen das sind unglaubliche
20 0 1 hinter der sieben hat unsere erde
ein zweiter mond dass es auch ein
spannendes video also nicht lange
fackeln anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran